guys I don't know how to say this why am
I in a room with no furniture or
apparently anything where it's the
poster where is the closet where is this
beautiful collection of Gundam I know I
know
let's it kick me out that's right
[Music]
I'm joking Mike said we're still fine
right
that's not edited in audio she's
actually there I promise and we have a
new intro I I've seen this one before
it's the top rated one of all time come
on this has to be the new intro let's
look at this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's it's beautiful and unoriginal at
the same time just the way I like it
very nice Amos Dindin
you did good well done should we keep
that as an intro let me know let me know
I like it I think it's cool we should
definitely use okay great
[Music]
this better make it into love yok
entitled me myrrh
[Music]
I don't know I really Wall Street
Journal headline famous youtuber
creative Peter Piper mercilessly attacks
endangered frogs Beezus
why would I attack my own species it's
not like my own pet died really really
solid editing here you can barely tell
that best photo in post that's almost as
good as the moustache of Superman
incredible well done
oopsie ten jokes that went too far Logan
Paul's birth weight he's 95 damn okay
well this explains a lot upload if you
want appears to do a whole 10 minute
video of him just clapping and saying
meme review yeah I'm sure you guys would
love that
hey I'll do these post videos every once
in a while and they all the comments are
just like I don't get it
why is he just clapping stupid idiots
your bunch of morons you're a bunch of
dummy dummy bum bum pants that's right
on the prepay channel I called you guys
out now I fight back if you are damned
this noise is so quick and goes so close
huh I can fight you back you're on fire
hahaha this is what happens when you
don't have internet realizes he has this
internet in the world it is Internet Hey
look at that
looks like someone doesn't hurt anymore
just have to move countries guys that's
all you have to do to get a good
internet I can't believe people let it
I'll realize this when you're alive when
you're dead
when Peter pie starts asking if we have
enough for foetus me it's so sad we
never really have time for bonus meme I
try my best to make sure I'm getting
real sick of recording bonus meme and
they doesn't end up in the damn bonus
mean I'm not
that control since Brad and cyber right
so it really if you guys want bonus
means so badly I think you're gonna have
to mooch up from them in that meet you
to our tube that's right everybody way
better understand what capitalism
communism is okay just cuz money goes to
everyone else doesn't mean it's
communism I'm Swedish okay I know all
about it
i 3d printed the PT paycheck please send
it to me I miss him so much
look at the logo that's 10 out of 10 I
could spin around but incredible science
this is top science stuff Elon Musk will
be impressed I'm sure well done that's
honestly pretty cool I like this new
direction I don't know why but just for
now communists memes are just fine it's
like a meme that we can enjoy until the
media ruins yet another meme but for now
it's great do you smoke
yes every time the wire gets monetized
you are in perfect health yeah why is
the only video I have that actually is
fine every week it's fine
guess that means y'all post pussy-ass
memes does Marzia know about this so sad
this is so sad who
for every boob I see I will look at 200
books
it's really weird I don't think I've
ever read this much in my entire life it
just happened that's pretty good
research this is almost better than the
Wall Street Journal main well if then is
that true I gotta check this no it's
still ali-a
where am I where hey all right let's see
what Le a is doing that real life done
oh how many good for him look at all
these mid rolls good for you good you
had just one two three four five six
seven just seven of them that's great
good for you Ali a good good for you how
many minerals do I get in my videos as
many times as I dine video games why why
is it because I save a Ghana I need
answers like date have you heard about
it I went to Iceland for you piers Wow
we're at the same spot can you picked an
actual monument that I went to and just
like these random set of houses where's
the beard then huh hmm
fortnight cringe I'm going to finally
play fortnight guys I'm just joking what
did you think I'm just some pathetic
that relief that's right God don't worry
guys I will never play fortnight and
it's not like I played it before it was
even out because I got an early copy and
they were actually really nice guys
working at that company but now for some
reason I'm just being a complete dick
about it look at this
Ant Man - one two - reposting memes from
granny pathetic I mean I'm proud this is
how it's done
you don't post memes in the Peter Pan
subreddit you steal memes this is all
theft what the f was
cuz he grabbed me we're going in for a
high five and he grabbed me guys
stop putting example of me not doing
high fives or handshakes okay I know how
to do it I swear to God if you ever meet
me perfect
here's the thing Conan who goes in he
waited for a handshake during high five
well you don't grab midair who grabs me
they Ethan what's wrong with you
god damnit wife is my legacy oh my god
damn I got an ad on my videos incredible
and I look so good I have to blend my
ads maybe with my content now it's the
only way to do it
last week my drawing didn't make it into
LA why I'm trying one more time thanks
for support fellas I actually reacted to
this so that means brighter side cut it
out dude it means I liked it but they
didn't that's right everybody I made a
picture of crying PewDiePie out of the
monetization signs to make it ten
minutes so you can put another okay
alright it's the only brand Eli gun is
so long please guys please down a little
bit like some more brands will like me
please I draw and turn people into
demons so I made one for Felix - it's
almost like you can't tell a difference
that's that's really cool it reminds me
of the Deaf's training poster thank you
namaste that looks very nice well well
what what is this
how did we get mods in this subreddit I
did not mod anyone feel free to post
whatever you want okay there's no rules
from the pewdiepie subreddit make sure
you post your memes down in below really
good means this week good job good job
you get it you got a plus you get across
every
what are you gonna do with it what are
you gonna do with that huh all right so
I'm in Japan
I'm gonna stay here for a month I'm
gonna try to make videos while I'm still
here
the setup is still in progress so it's
kind of messy but hopefully this will be
all right anyway
I know it's not the same but yeah thumbs
up this video and as always bro does it
look like the mic is coming out of me